ونحييكم الى ملفنا الثالث يوصل رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
مواجهه قرار المحكمه العليا القاضي بشطبي
تعيين رئيسي حزب شات الدينيه درعي وزيرا
في الحكومه بسبب ادانته السابقه بقضيه
الفساد الماليه حيث ذكرت تقارير اخباريه
ان المستشاره القضائيه للحكومه طلبت منك
ياهو تنحيه درع من منصبه بعد القرار الذي
تم اتخاذه داخل المحكمه العليا باسرائيل
باغلبيه عشرتي مقابل رفض قاض واحد الغاء
تعيين رئيس حزب فاس شكل ضربه قويه
لائتلافنا له الحكومي وفقه مراقبين وهو ما
سيدفع نتنياهو لتسريع التشريعات المتعلقه
بالقضاء لاعاده درعي الى منصبه من خلال
قرارات الكنيسه على قارات القضاء وتامين
اغلبيه بحسب المصدرين نفسها قرار المحكمه
العليا جاء رغم قيامه وزير العدل
الاسرائيلي بعرضه اضعاف قضاء عاشيه
المداولات في ملفات درعي وهو ما يراه
مراقبون للتطورات الحاصله تهديدا للنظام
القضائي الاسرائيلي الذي من المتوقع ان
يحاكمه رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو في ثلاث
قضايا ويعد ارى درع احد اهم اركان حكومه
نتنياهو ما سيزيد حدث التوتر المتفاقمه
بالفعل بين حكومته في المحكمه العليا في
اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
هناك هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من تل ابيب عبر
زوما الدكتور
في شؤون الشرق الاوسط اهلا بكم من القدس
يا استاذ العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه
العبريه
دكتور ان يطالب القضاء باي شيء كان
الحكومه هذا لا يعتبر تدخل قضائي في شؤون
السياسيه
مساء الخير لكي ولا المشاهدين
لحد الان
موضوع
التدخل للمحكمه العدل الاولى في الشؤون
السياسيه المتعلقه باتخاذ القرار والتنفيذ
في دوله اسرائيل والتي اساسيه اساس باساس
القضيه لازم يفصل بين سلطات الثلاثه
السلطات
هو الموضوع التي الذي يدور نقاش حوله
يعني هذا القرار هو بمصابه تدخل فظيع في
شئون سياسيه اسرائيليه وهذا ياتي من خلال
مصطلح جديد في عالم القضاء
الترجمه من العبريه الى مصطلح عربي قد
يسمى احتماليه
والاحتماليه تحتوي فيتايتها
16000 تفسير يرجع الى ما يريده وعلى ما في
بال القوي
قد يقول البعض بان هذا تدخل مشروع لان هذه
الشخصيه معروفه كذلك منذ البدايه وكانت
هناك تحذيرات من دخول الحكومه وهنا السؤول
سؤال لك دكتور همم هل يمكن لهذا القرار ان
يؤثر على حكوماتنا نتنياهو تعتقد لانه
تهرب ضريبي متهم به درعي وهناك همم
مناشدات باخراجه من الحكومه
شكرا لكم على الاستضافه استاذه ريم دي
حياتي لك والضيفك صديقي الدكتور
اولا فيما يتعلق بهذا الموضوع
مساله استبعاد وزير او مرشح لمنصب وزير
بسبب
تهم بسبب انه تحت الطاوله هذه ليست اول
مره تحدث في اسرائيل
سيد قرار المحكمه وقال نعم انه لا يصح
لشخص ان يتولى الوزاره انه تحت طائله
المساءله القانونيه هذا هذا قانون في
اسرائيل وهذا القانون قانون اساس قانون
الحكومه
والرسائل المحكمه العليا تقرر وفقا لهذه
القوانين ليست وفقا لميزاج القضاه او
الاهواء القضاه وانما وفقد
القانون اذا هذا حدث في الماضي هذا لا
يشكل اي اشكاليه من الممكن ان شخص اخر
دكتور دكتور
صحيح ولكن بخصوص هذه النقطه قبل الانتقال
لنقطه الاخرى بخصوصها السيد را اوفين همم
لا يتفق معك فلا اعلم سيدرا وفيهم ان كنت
تتفق على جزئيه قانونيه ام لديك رؤيه
بختصار التعليقات
المحكمه لم تجد اي مبرر
ليبعثه لاقالته الا مصطلح الاحتماليه لانه
ودينا
في الماضي وقد يعني همم
وبعد ذلك
يقول لك بانه هذا ليس قرار همم اتى بناء
على
همم يعني ارى قضاه هذا قرار اتى على همم
او بناءا على قانون
لم يدين ولم يمنع من السيد درعي بمشاركه
او بتعيينه للحكومه القانون على ما هو لا
يمن ذلك ولكن الاتجاه الى
المصطلح الاحتماليه وهو ملجا من لا يريد
التمسك بالقانون بلسانه
ونقاتا على خروفه هذا هو اللي اودى
بالقضاه بشكل
وضحت الفكره ولكن دكتور همم اعلم بانه هذا
نقطه قد تسيل كثير من الجدل هل هي
احتماليه هل هو التدخل في شؤون الحكومه
ولكن مهما تكون التفاصيل هل يمكن لينا
نتنياه ان ينصع لهذا القرار وان همم يخرج
همم همم دار عيب من حكومته تعتقد
اي خيار اخر وهو مضطر يفعل هذا لان هذا هو
قرار المحكمه وبالتالي هو سوف يختار شخص
اخر يرشحه حزب شخص وهذا حدث بالماضي في
الماضي كان درعي نفسه همم رئيسا للحفظ
واستبعد على خلفيه مساء على قضائيه واتهم
وادانا وسجن لان هو سياده الوزير رد سجون
كان في السجن في الماضي اختلاس ملعام وهمم
وفساد ومعترف بهذا هذا كان في الماضي ووجد
لثانيه شخص اخر انذاك السيد اللي شاي وكان
هو ممثل شاس في الحكومه رئيس شاص بشكل
مؤقت حتى عاد مره اخرى الى الحياه
السياسيه لمره اخرى همم يتم التحقيق معه
في على خلفيه قضيه تهرب ضريبي تهرب ضريبي
اذن هذه مصر هذه مساله رايناها في الماضي
هذا ليست ولكن القديم القديم
على فكره ضيفه ثانيه تحدث فلو هناك
امكانيه نستمع له
انا اقول السيد الدكتور
الجبل او لدى فار لم يتبع من هذه الشيء
ولذلك من ناحيه قانونيه عندما تم تحقيق
وصلنا الى من ناحيه المحكمه الطريق
العنوان احتماليه تعيينه ولكن اذا اردنا
ان نبحث السؤال التالي هل ينساه رئيس
الحكومه لهذا القرار نعم ولكن هذا يعني
فيه ما يصدق ويقوي
المطلب للتغيير بنود
او النفوس المحكمه باتخاذ قرارات
ساعه لقرار المحكمه ولكن هل سيؤثر هذا
الخروج او هذه همم هذا التصعيد او هذا
التطور في حكومه نتنياهو
من وزير القوى القويه
انا اعتقد انه سياسيا لا يوضع في الحكومه
ولكن ادبيا يضعفها حيث انه طبعا اتهامات
المعارضه في اسرائيل الحكومه بانها حكومه
فاسدين وانها حكومه لا تحترم القانون
وطبعا نحن نعرف ان القانون فوق الجميع
ولكن هناك كثير من التحويلات
ماركو بحث شؤون الشرق الاوسط
السلام عليكم